82% of soldiers in battle suffer from traumatic
limb injuries. Many of these injuries are
large bone defects. Engineers at MIT are trying
to create materials that mimic the function
of the bone's natural healing processes. The
structure and properties of these materials
promote bone regeneration. This video is part
of the Structure-Function-Properties video
series. The structure, function, and properties
of a system are related and depend on the
processes that define or create the system.
Hi, my name is Nisarg Shah, and I am a graduate
student in Professor Paula Hammond's lab in
the chemical engineering department at MIT.
In the Hammond Lab, we design novel materials
for tissue engineering, gene and drug delivery,
and energy applications. My research in particular,
focuses on developing and assembling different
materials for bone tissue regeneration.
Before watching this video, you should be
familiar with the concepts of pH and pKa,
and with the common chemical functional groups.
After watching this video, you will be able
to explain how the concepts of pH and pKa
are useful in the design of materials via
layer-by-layer assembly. Many of the materials
our lab develops are based on a technique
called layer-by-layer assembly. Layer- by-layer
assembly utilizes electrostatic interactions
to create layers of chemical species of alternating
charge. These chemical species could be anything
-- polymers, proteins, small molecules -- the
key is that they have the appropriate positive
or negative charge to incorporate them into
the film.
We assemble these films using a simple dip
method. First, we take our substrate or surface
that we wish to coat and bombard it with free
radical oxygen in an instrument called a plasma
cleaner. This not only cleans the surface
of contaminants, but also leaves the surface
with a negative charge. Next, we take our
substrate and dip it into a solution of positively
charged molecules. The molecules in solution
bind to the substrate because of Coulombic
interactions.
This process is self-adsorption limited, meaning
that once the newly adsorbed layer neutralizes
the charged sites on the surface, additional
molecules will not bind. This creates layers
that are on the order of nanometers thick.
After a rinse step to remove any unbound components,
the substrate is dipped into a solution of
negatively charged molecules. Interactions
with the charges on the previous layer allow
a new layer to be deposited. Again, we would
rinse to remove any unbound components. We
can continue this process and dip our growing
film into solutions of positively and negatively
charged molecules, with rinse steps in between,
building up our coating layer-by-layer. Many
of the films I work with have on the order
of 40 layers. We use polymers in many of our
layers. These long chain, high molecular weight
molecules form more stable layers than small
molecules. The long polymer chains from one
layer weave through other layers creating
an interlocking structure. Also, because we
use negatively and positively charged polymers
in these layers, the polymers ionically crosslink,
adding to the stability of the overall film.
Polymers whose repeating unit contains a charged
group are called polyelectrolytes. Thus, many
people refer to the films that we create as
polyelectrolyte multilayers. For every polymer
or small molecule I incorporate into my layer-by-layer
assembly, I have to be mindful of it's pKa
and select appropriate assembly conditions
to ensure they have the desired charge. For
example, one of the polymers that I use in
a layer-by-layer assembly is polyacrylic acid.
You don't need to worry about it's exact chemical
structure. The important thing to note is
the repeating carboxylic acid group. Another
polymer that I use in my layer-by-layer assembly
contains repeating amine groups. Let's say
I'm creating my layer-by-layer assembly at
a pH equal to 4. If the pKa of the carboxylic
acid groups on our first polymer is approximately
4.5, and the pKa of the amine groups on our
second polymer is approximately 6.5, what
would the charge on each of these polymers
be? Pause the video and take a moment to think
about it. At a pH of 4, some of the carboxylic
acid groups on our first polymer would be
deprotonated, resulting in a negative charge.
At the same pH, some of the amine groups on
our second polymer pick up an extra hydrogen,
resulting in a positive charge. Because so
many molecules could be viable candidates
for incorporation into these films, they are
being used in a wide variety of applications.
My main interest is using these films in tissue
engineering applications.
So, first I have to ask myself, what problem
do I want to solve? Then, I have to ask myself
how these multilayer films could be useful.
What function do they need to have? What properties
of the film would help to achieve that function?
Taking all of this into account, how should
I structure my film?
One of the problems I became particularly
interested in is that of large bone defects.
Large bone defects are large gaps in the bone
that result from trauma.
Although bone is capable of regeneration,
when there are large defects, some sort of
intervention therapy is needed to bridge the
defect for proper healing.
These intervention therapies typically involve
taking bone tissue either from another location
in the patient's body or from a deceased donor
source and grafting it into the defect site.
While bone taken from the patient may be immune
compatible and be more viable, this method
has limitations. Tissue injury and trauma
at the site of bone removal causes patients
pain and long healing times. Bone tissue from
a deceased donor may cause an unfavorable
immune response. The processes used to prepare
these tissues for implantation may also compromise
their mechanical properties.
Our lab had an idea for a possible solution
to this problem. We asked ourselves, can we
design a scaffold to bridge these large defects
that will stimulate the growth of new bone
tissue? The idea was to create a rigid, porous
scaffold coated with a multilayer film. The
multilayer film would deliver biological molecules
that would stimulate the growth of bone both
on the surface and throughout the scaffold.
Over time, the scaffold would slowly degrade,
leaving the new bone tissue behind. In selecting
components for both the scaffold and these
films, we looked to the biological process
of wound healing for inspiration. The idea
was that if we could mimic the wound healing
process in bone, we could potentially regenerate
tissue that is mechanically and chemically
identical to native bone tissue.
The bulk of our scaffold consisted of a polymer
that would slowly degrade when placed in the
body. This polymer was mixed with calcium
phosphate, a significant component of native
bone. Our thought was that calcium phosphate
would promote the attachment, growth, and
migration of cells that produce bone tissue
within the scaffold.
We then used layer-by-layer assembly to create
a multilayered film on the surface of the
scaffold. The film contained layers of polymers
and layers of biological molecules that we
wanted to release into the defect site. One
of the molecules was a protein called bone
morphogenetic protein-2. This protein is a
growth factor that stimulates mesenchymal
stem cells from the bone marrow to transform
into bone tissue producing cells.
The biodegradable properties of the polymers
we used in the film would help to release
the protein into the surrounding tissue when
the scaffold is implanted.
In addition to identifying molecules that
would give us the function and properties
that we desired, we had to choose an assembly
pH that would ensure they had the desired
charge.
To test our hypothesis that these materials
would lead to bone growth, we implanted our
coated scaffold into a rat quadriceps muscle.
In this model, the scaffold was placed in
a location where bone is not normally found,
so that we would know that any bone created
on the scaffold was due to the coating.
Our experiments were successful in that we
saw the deposition of bone minerals and collagen
on our scaffolds within 4 weeks. Of course,
there are more experiments to be done to see
if this system will work in the same way in
a large defect site.
The main lesson I learned in these experiments
was that for bone tissue regeneration to occur,
my multilayer-coated scaffolds needed to provide
two key functions: to encourage bone producing
cells to attach, migrate through, and deposit
tissue in the scaffold; and to encourage mesenchymal
stem cells to transform into bone producing
cells.
In this video, we hope that you saw how general
chemistry concepts such as pH and pKa continue
to be useful beyond the classroom and into
research settings. Here, we saw how we need
We also saw how considering the desired function
and properties of a material can help us rationally
design its structure.